les négociations continuent entre
ukrainiens et russes mais elle semble
mal se passer d'après moscou l'ukraine
aurait présenté un projet d'accord de
paix inacceptable d'après les russes et
puis côté sanctions les européens
n'arrivent visiblement pas accordé leurs
violons on attend depuis mardi la
nouvelle salve de sanctions contre les
russes la commission avait proposé à
l'embargo sur le charbon mais il y à des
blocages bonjour caroline de camaret la
décision pourrait tomber aujourd'hui ou
demain pourquoi ça prend autant de temps
alors c'est vrai que en fait c'était
pour réagir a effectivement aux images
terribles de butch à l'union européenne
la commission a préparé ce cinquième un
paquet de sanctions
simplement il y a des réfractaires parmi
les vingt-sept et en particulier on
parle de couper le charbon russe
l'allemagne
l'allemagne commence à avoir des
difficultés énergétiques et est
d'ailleurs différents obstacles qui est
un ancien premier ministre belge a dit
que ce cinquième round il n'avait eu
aucun effet sur vladimir poutine tout
simplement parce qu'on vous aider des
sanctions gradé une stratégie qui ne
fonctionne pas la progressivité dans une
autocratie et non pas une démocratie au
l'opinion publique peut peser là ça
n'est pas le cas elle est contrôlée
cette opinion publique donc il dit que
le charbon ça représente à peine 3% des
importations européennes de la russie et
donc c'est négligeable quand aux
oligarques il faudrait six mille
personnes autour de l'avenue poutine qui
est prévue pour l'instant dans le paquet
c'est effectivement de nouveaux noms sur
la liste sur la liste noire notamment
les deux filles du président et des
oligarques russes mais pas pas autant et
puis c'est aussi donc l'interdiction du
charbon à l'orge du charbon c'est en
effet une petite quantité mais tout de
même 46 % de celui qu'on importe vient
de russie donc c'est déjà un effort
considérable que veulent s'accorder les
européens on n'y arrive pas pour le
pétrole et le gaz pour l'instant qui
sont à 20% et 40% de nos importations
parce que là en effet sa bloquerait
beaucoup de pays de l'est et l'allemagne
est là pourtant joseph bourrel le
le chef de la diplomatie et le président
du conseil européen dit que des mesures
de sur le pétrole et le gaz seront
nécessaires tôt ou tard donc c'est le
pas supplémentaire qu'il faudra à gré en
faisant beaucoup de mal à nos économies
mais ça bloque les clichés les allemands
chez les hongrois alors justement les
ukrainiens eux ils pointent en
particulier la personnalité de viktor
orban qui est accusé directement par
kiev de saper l'unité de l'union
européenne est d'aider un poutine a
continué son agression contre l'ukraine
puisqu'elle s'est dit prête à acheter
son gaz en roubles alors que tous les
autres ont dit qu'en aucun cas ils
continuer avec l'euro et les autres
devises occidentales
c'est vrai que viktor orban se félicite
d'avoir été réélu pour un quatrième
mandat dans des conditions de liberté de
la presse très limites et deux jours
après cette victoire et bien cette
quatrième victoire d'affilée pour ce
souverainiste la commission européenne
s'est décidée à lancer une procédure
contre la hongrie procédure inédite qui
permet de suspendre les fonds européens
en cas de violation d'état de droit il
s'agit tout de même pour la hongrie
d'encaisser sept milliards d'euros au
titre du plan de relance qui pour
l'instant est gelée et on regarde ce qui
se passe sur le soin selon croire un
premier avion transportant du nucléaire
en provenance de russie est arrivée en
hongrie ça veut dire que les russes
continuent à livrer cette énergie qui
n'est pas frappé par les sanctions pour
l'instant en hongrie et son bienvenue
sur le sol de hongrie alors que de
l'autre côté les hongrois ne laisse pas
passer le matériel militaire nécessaire
à l'ukraine dans l'autre sens merci
beaucoup caroline